"NCIS" has stood head and shoulders above
most of its police procedural peers for years,
thanks to its lovable cast of eclectic characters
and almost uncanny longevity. The CBS show has
been running since 2003, and the ongoing Season
19 finds the series as strong as usual. However,
it's clear that the show's arguably most massive
change yet is on the not-too-distant horizon,
and it's been looking that way for a while.
For 18 years, the stalwart leader of the
titular investigation team in "NCIS" has been
Leroy Jethro Gibbs played by Mark Harmon,
who was the backbone of the show
throughout its first 18 seasons.
Season 19 of "NCIS" has revealed that new
developments — along with 18 seasons of
hard-hitting investigations weighing
down on his broad shoulders — have
caused Gibbs to decide that
he's done with his NCIS job,
and that he's planning to carve a new
life for himself in Alaska. It's an
understandable development for the character
for anyone who watched the Season 18 finale.
The episode showed Gibbs boarding a boat that
wasn't destined to last long. As it sailed out
to sea, it unexpectedly blew up. Fortunately,
fans saw Gibbs' body not long afterward with him
soon swimming to shore. It let everyone know Gibbs
would return for Season 19, but it definitely gave
the impression he wasn't going to be around much
longer. But what, exactly, caused the character to
decide so — or rather, what prompted Mark Harmon
to join the many actors who have left "NCIS?"
The Hollywood Reporter states Mark Harmon's exit
from the show is a pretty final one — at least,
in his starring capacity. After all, the star
has only signed for a limited amount of episodes
for Season 19, and Gibbs' decision to remain in
Alaska pretty much removes him from the fabric
of the show for the foreseeable future. What's
more, the ongoing season features some brand
new star power in the form of Katrina Law
and rumored Harmon replacement Gary Cole.
Harmon's limited-episode deal means that Gibbs has
effectively left his active role in the
show behind, but showrunner Steven D.
Binder is quick to note that the actor
will maintain a behind-the-scenes role,
and there's always a chance for an
on-screen comeback, as well. Binder stated,
"As an executive producer and dear friend,
Mark continues to be an integral part of
the fabric of the show. Our north star has
always been staying true to our characters,
and that truth has always guided
the stories we tell and where those
characters go. So regarding the future
of Gibbs, as long-time fans of the show
may have noticed over the years ...
never count Leroy Jethro Gibbs out."
That means viewers may not have shed
their last tears over Gibbs just yet.
If we were into betting, we'd be
willing to put down money on Mark
Harmon returning for the series
finale ... whenever that occurs.
It's hard to say goodbye to a beloved TV
character, especially one who's been on the
air for nearly two decades. Leroy Jethro Gibbs
starred in hundreds of "NCIS" episodes and has
earned a special place in people's hearts.
The show just won't be the same without him,
and fans have already taken to social media to let
their thoughts known on the emotional departure.
It's entirely possible his final scene of
fishing on a lake in the great unknown will
be the last time audiences see Gibbs,
but at least he received the send-off
he so richly deserved. Fans were quick to
chime in with their thoughts. One fan wrote,
"I am sad Gibbs [is] leaving
NCIS.. But [got to] respect
and applaud Mark Harmon [for] his
performance thru 18 years as Gibbs."
Another fan noted,
"I just learned Mark Harmon is leaving
NCIS and I'm in complete shock.
I grew up with NCIS and especially with
agent Leroy Jethro Gibbs but he did his
time and I'm really proud. He
had such an amazing journey."
Gibbs has certainly come a long way ever since
he first graced people's screens on the episode
"Ice Queen" on "JAG." He'd only appear on
one more "JAG" episode before spinning off
into "NCIS," where he's been ever since.
Harmon walked away when the time was right,
just like the great Gibbs so famously
said, "When the job is done, walk away."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.